Uh, did you see that the monkey stole the virus? Corona virus.
His gang rail monkey stolen. Hey, uh, we gotta get rid of monkeys.
Okay. Like straight up, they have hands and they have date.
Like you could be like, Hey monkey. And they'll be like,
we gotta get rid of any kind of animals that have hands. Right?
What are they? People, do you know what I'm saying?
According to that one girl with a Tik TOK, we're authentic being, but dude,
pretty sure we got to get rid of monkeys, dude. Okay.
If they can steal a virus that can murder the world. Well,
you got to get rid of monkeys. All right. I would go overboard and just say,
we also got to get rid of the banned the monkeys,
but I think they must be mostly dead yet or 90. Um, man,
I used to watch the out of the monkeys dude.
But dome. Hey Erica.
I'm walking down the street. I'm sorry. Didn't mean to sing that good, good,
good time.
But then every one we meet dad with the man gaze didn't mean to sing that. Well,
dude, I ripped that song, man. People say a monkey around
[inaudible] back when I sing that song,
didn't know I could sing that song that well. Okay,
well we've got to get rid of monkeys, dude.
They're going to be stealing viruses, dude.
That's like that movie planet of the apes dude
thought that was legit. Nith it's like that movie planet of the apes.
God dude. Monkey stole a virus
or you think that's fake. That's not fake news. Dude.
Monkey steel virus.
And they're just chilling. There's a picture of a monkey chilling with a vial,
just like this. Killing, kidding monkey steals.
COVID-19 test samples from health worker in India.
Hey dude, I have a question.
Why are monkeys remotely close to that?
Hey, Hey,
keep your monkeys and viruses of far apart
and that's obvious. Oh it. Monkey with a vial.
Just chilling in a bar later does like, you know what?
I still what? The coronavirus,
the outta here. Not really look it's right here. What?
Why were you even close to that? Yeah. I don't know. Indians are nuts, man.
They'll put monkeys near the viruses nearby vials. Monkey.
Shouldn't I have a monkey and I don't I'll say it.
We shouldn't even be near a glass period. This vial right here, glass.
I got it from a Indian guy. Really?
What are you gonna do with it? You think? I know I'm a monkey.
I might throw it or eat it or try and put it in my. I'm a monkey.
Who knows what I'm going to do with it? I shouldn't even be talking right now.
Monkeys mobbed, an Indian health worker and made off with bloods. Dude.
What is this world?
Monkeys mobbed in Indian health worker and made off with blood samples from
coronavirus tests, prompting fears.
They could have spread the virus in the local area.
After making off with the three samples,
they took three dude. They took one.
And then either this is how this went. One took one and then,
Oh, not done yet. Took another one. And then he goes, you thought that was it?
And took a third one.
Either that happened or three monkeys took one eight inch.
That's Hey, get rid of monkeys. Hey monkeys. You had your day.
Great tired of y'all swinging around stealing viral, viral vials. You're out,
dude. You go, go, go, go. Either. I tell you what this is.
It either get rid of all the monkeys or dress them up like people and then just
have them out because the reason I'm not doing this, uh, wait, hold on.
There's a monkey out. What? What's the deal here? I'm either.
The monkey is going to be us or
done. I'm no I'm talking about kill them. All kill all the monkeys.
There's going to be no gray area here.
If a monkey could steal a vile,
either murder all the monkeys or give them driver's licenses, dude.
And I'm not around. Give them all hats and caps and over. I don't give a.
Clothe them. If they're around naked,
then the cops got to take them in for indecent exposure.
I'm talking about monkeys are people.
Now you thought that the Corona virus was.
Monkeys are people okay? Dress them up.
Put pants on that monkey. Hey, I got three vows.
Really? Yeah.
Monkey runaway with Corona test samples, locals theory. Here's a video of it.
He's up at the tree with it.
He's up in the tree with it.
[inaudible].
How nervous do they sound? Okay man. Okay. Wait. Okay.
Oh, the guy did it.
Hey man, the monkey has the vial.
It guy's got a tray. I've got it, dude. Imagine,
ah. We need our top line of defense. Ah. Who are we going to cut?
And I got the guy to call and a bad-ass comes in like a Jason,
stay them on a motorcycle or in like a McLaren.
And he pulls up and he pops out and he's like,
I got this and walks up to the monkey and he's like gas.
Even Jason stay. Even the Indian Jason, stay them. Couldn't do it. No, no, no.
I got a guy. Stand back. There he goes. So I'm running after him.
I got him as he's running.
[inaudible] really going to
kill you. [inaudible].
He's got three vials back. There's two more, but two more vials
guys. Just in different directions. There's three of them. [inaudible]
and one monkey falls for it. Guys. He's doing that guys. I'll be right back.
I just want to go see what he wants. So maybe he's got bread or something. No,
don't fall for it. No, no, no. It's going to be fine. It's going to be fine.
Hey, get closer. Got them. Get the vial. Ah. Ah,
get away. I knew he didn't have bread. Go
running out of running out of a building like it's fast.
And the furious jumped from one building through a window,
into another building. Slow motion in the air. The monkeys got the viral viral,
making it into the window.
The other and the Indian Jason say is just follows them out of the air in slow
motion. Just like this
in slow motion.
I get one of the files left,
but there's still 90 minutes left in this movie and we need to get two more.
Dress him up. All right, babies.
I think that's it. We'll end on that one.